foreign
so for our first talk today we have Luke
odame and he will be giving us the
second part of cancer decompositions
okay well I was trying to get a head
start on the day today because
um we uh stopped before I got to tell
you about tests for Border rank or
expected rank for tensor so let's just
go uh and talk about this for a second
so the first thing we mentioned in the
in the that I mentioned in the
discussion after the lecture last time
is that we had this Subspace variety
which is the variety in which of tensors
for which you can use less tensor
coordinates and up to change of
coordinates and that always contains the
Earth secant variety of the segregate
products so the Border rank R tensors
always have the r plus one by R plus one
miners of one flattening Vanishing on
them and you can think about other types
of flattenings where I collect more than
just one vector space at a time I think
that was Professor sternpel's question
uh motivated by that there's much more
interesting things to know when you
collect more than one vector space on
one side of the of the
of the flattening so
um a lot of people have worked in this
area so I tried to collect some of the
names so for the second secant variety
Garcia's domain and sternfels
conjectured that the three by three
miners have flattening suffice to Define
this variety and that was proven in many
many different cases by Landsberg
Mandeville women Claudia uriku has the
most refined version of this statement
improved the full force of their
conjecture and also a generalization of
their conjecture with materials mihalic
and pyoto zernik we also described a lot
of the local properties of this Variety
in any characteristic so
the point is that the second secant
variety the bordering two tensors are
defined by all the three by three miners
of the one and two flattening so you
actually need sometimes to collect two
of the vector spaces on one side of the
flattening and not just only one vector
space on one side okay but then what
happens when flattening's run out
flattenings are not the end of the story
so when flattening's run out a recent
result of Yang Chi is that the third
secant variety of any number of factors
of the segreg product is defined by the
equations that you might have expected
well the four by four miners the
flattenings but also you need strassen's
degree four equations and if I have a
moment at the end I'll describe more
what these equations are so it turns out
that two classes of equations to find
the third secant variety
so then we look at the fourth secant
variety and things get a bit harder as
far as I know we don't know a lot more
for a general n and more than three
factors but in three factors again
several people worked independently and
together on these prod on this on this
variety there was a big conjecture or a
question by Elizabeth Allman on this on
this variety as well so Landsberg
Mandeville made a huge reduction
Friedland made a very big progress with
Dan Bates and myself we use bertini to
make another step in this direction and
then Friedland and gross also made a big
contribution probably the most important
in there though is frosted strassen yeah
let me not forget straws and his name
will show up in a second
so this variety is defined the fourth
secant variety of a triple segreg
product is defined by five by five
miners of flattenings
strassen's degree five equations
strassan's degree 9 equations
and somewhat possibly more mysterious is
Landsberg
and Annabelle's
degree 6 equations
and as a set those are in so the point
is like maybe as an ideal the deal may
have more equations in it that are
necessary but we don't know that yet but
at least these equations suffice
to tell you precisely when you have
board rank four for a triple secondary
product so uh these equations
um these are pretty straightforward
these are found by representation
theoretic methods much like what
Christian eichenmeyer is talking about
in his talk
okay so that's how you can check at
least the lowest border rank for
um for non-symmetric tensors
okay great so let's go back to the the
beginning of last lecture where I had
everyone whose birthday was in September
say tensor and whose birthday was not in
September say something else so here's
my my recollection of what happened so
somebody said donut somebody else say
bagel someone else said coffee and
someone in the audience said tensor all
right and what what I heard was just the
amalgamation of everything and the goal
of today is to gonna be to describe how
to add redundancy to the picture so that
we can actually recover what everybody
said in the room
okay that's our goal so it turns out
that if what we did is we said well I
really want to say tensor a lot of times
Etc and I'm going to repeat all the
other words several times so
this is a communication scheme inspired
by CDMA technology which is code
division multiple access cell phone
technology and in in
Pierre camon's lab in France they they
actually are interested in this type of
tensor decomposition which is often
called wearing composition
so the idea is a tree
each signal
say L1
down to L sub R the r people that spoke
as a linear combination so this will be
say
A1 X1 plus plus a so n x of n in this
next one L2 will be B1 x 1 plus plus b n
x and n and the last one will say bc1 X1
Plus
and as we know if we add several vectors
together there's no way to recover the
the sum ends right if I add two integers
together you don't know and I gave you
the result you don't know what integers
I started with right so the trick here
is to say tensor many times so we're
going to raise each one of these guys to
the Neath power
and we're going to send this
so we're going to send beef powers and
then what we're going to receive
is going to be this linear combination
of the l i to the D
and our goal so why is this called
wearing decomposition wearing maybe 400
years ago is interested in solving this
problem for integers and prime numbers
but we're interested in solving this
problem for polynomials so this is going
to be our say F and then try
to recover
the Li
uniquely
so that's the goal that's what we're
trying to do so naively uh the way I've
set up here is a very large system of
polynomial equations of degree D on R
times n variables
right
so the the a i b i c i are variables our
parameters
and then the X's are just going to be
thought of as placeholders and I have
many
many degree
B equations
for instance uh what is uh the
coefficient on X1 to the D
over here well on one hand it's f
1 1 1 1.
is equal to well all the ways that I can
get X1 to the D out of all of these
summons right so it's A1 to the D plus
B1 to the D Plus
plus c one to the D all right that's my
first equation that I have and then
what's f 2 1 1 1 well this is all the
ways of getting two
a two and the rest one so A1 to the D
minus one a two plus
e one to the D minus one B two plus plus
of course C One D minus one C two
Etc
so this is how you write down the system
of equations that you would have to
solve in order to find these things
okay so we all picture
so if you get bored during the lecture
try this for um playing cubics
can you solve this problem for plain
cubics so the last time I checked using
proteini
and 50 processors
this took on the level of you know one
minute
so
solve this problem means recover the A's
B's and C's that's right from the F's
from the F's so I'm going to give you
you know somebody see that the thing
here is I'm not going to give you random
F's I'm going to choose rational numbers
a A's B's and C's I'm going to raise
these pop forms to the dth power so I'm
going to cube them all and then I'm
going to send you the resulting
coefficients and I want you to try to
recover a b c and b and R is relatively
and R is going to be small like so take
R say less than or equal to 3 for
instance in this case but maybe you want
to even even worse try all the way up to
R less than or equal to five
okay so bratini can solve this problem
it's great right it's just a
straightforward system of equations but
one to two minutes on 50 processors
maybe too much computational time okay
and and you can imagine how this is
going to grow as soon as we go to
um maybe a couple more variables in a
little bit higher degree it's going to
be very hard to solve this problem we're
going to try to solve the first
instances of this problem much faster
than this Maybe by hand okay the first
instances of the problem
thank you
foreign
okay
there are other methods that you can
also use alternatingly squares you can
try to estimate
um
just a couple of things before we jump
into the algorithm that I have prepared
to just to solve this problem I just
want to give you a little bit more of
what to expect for these problems so
again we have the expected dimension
expected dimension of Sigma R of the N
so this is the Z risky closure of all of
the polynomials of the form L1 to the E
plus
plus l R to the D
that's that Li
all right c n plus one
okay so this this variety
well if you're just doing a parameter
count well I have just re-embedded PN so
I didn't change the dimension I'm going
to choose R Points from that
so I have R times n and then I choose a
point on the secant plane spanned by
those
so this is the expected dimension in
this guy
but it could also be
um
the dimension of the ambient space
okay so that's the dimension we expected
this variety so that means that we
expect
the max rank the rank
unexpected rank
is just this ratio
if you work it out okay so this is what
we expect the rank to be for these
varieties okay maybe if this isn't an
integer we don't expect a fractional
integer so pick the right integer just
next to this one what did you write next
to n plus one let me write it again
this is the dimension of the ambient
space divided by the dimension of the
variety
oh sorry sorry
goes here
are
is roughly this
okay
okay but this could fail so why did I
say expected Rank and I said last time
that for the segre variety
arbitrary number of factors we don't
know exactly when the expected rank is
the actual rank we don't know if the
expected Dimension is the expected
Dimension let me just point out that
Alexander
and hershovitz
around 1995 solved 100 year old problem
that
this Dimension is correct
except for when it's not
since you wrote it with a tilde is okay
it's correct except would be equal to
yeah anyway so this Dimension is correct
except for a small list of examples and
I don't want to dive into all of the
examples when it's not correct so there
is one infinite family there's about
five or six sporadic cases when the
expected Dimension is not equal to the
actual dimension of this variety and if
you're interested in looking at the
details please look at
um
maybe otabiani and and brembila's paper
has a shorter proof of this that you
could look at okay the last thing about
what to expect so this is what what I
should use
Haitian scheme is I I don't want to try
to use more
um people on on
I don't want a lot more people to talk
than I can actually recover their signal
and the the rank needs to be less than
or equal to this number so I'm going to
choose D depending on the number of
people are speaking n minus one or n
plus one
uh so that the rank is less than this
number so when the rank is less than
this number I expect to have finitely
many decomposition so let me tell you
why expect Finance decompositions here
so I need the incidence ready
so usually it's called an incidence
variety because it's much more General
than this but it's also called the
abstract secant variety
so abstract secant variety is just a
variety where nothing can go wrong so
it's called by cursive i it's just the
the pair the triples p
about multiples
X1
X of r
such that P is in the span
of x x i
language
okay so this is lives inside of
p n so
X as in p capital n
is the inside of the P capital N cross X
archives
it always has the correct dimension
dimension
of I
is just equal to R times the dimension
of x
stop plus r minus one
let's count parameters it always has the
correct Dimension and
well why is this important for
the uniqueness of wearing the
composition or intensity composition
we're going to use just very basic
algebra algebraic geometry
I have a projection but on to the first
factor which projects to
the artsecant variety of x
and if the dimensions agree then the
fiber is Zero Dimensional generically
okay so if the dimensions agree
that the variety upstairs has the same
Dimension as a variety downstairs then
generically
so generically
of course you can probably find some
fibers for which the dimensions or the
fiber is positive dimensional but most
of the time
with probability one you'll have
finitely many decompositions so if
you're given tensor as long as you're in
the low border end case so for for more
on this story there's several authors in
the last several years 2002 to
2006 and maybe also more recently 2014
there is Mela
Cantini
the taviani
valiko
and a very long name then using Hoven
I have to look at the well let me not
write all of his name sorry
is this is smooth already the incidents
variety well it depends on if x is
smooth right so that's a smooth 5x is
smoothies and it's just the Cartesian
product with all of these things with
this one
I mean the incidence variety
uh I have to think about it I'm not sure
because this instance maybe caused a
sense of singularities right
okay so if there's several people who
worked out worked out all of the
possibilities that um the the theme Here
is
if the rank
is sub-generic
expect
ancy compositions
they also have something to say about
when the rank is generic but um since we
get to decide our communication scheme
let's just stick in this up generic case
and we don't have to worry about the
rest of it
okay so
next now I'm going to talk about how to
find the decomposition yeah so any
questions about any one question
yeah so if the rank is less than generic
rank but the expected rank
then there should be finely mini
decompositions but there could be
exceptions so there's a there's again
one of these beautiful theorems in
algebraic geometry what do you expect is
true except when it isn't in the small
cases when it isn't are all beautiful
and interesting
yeah there's a small list where this can
fail and they tell you what steps we
also recorded the list in a paper at the
topic reference the first lecture
stay away from the small list
yeah same in case where everything is as
you expect right because we're gonna
hopefully someday talk to the engineers
and help them design a better
communication scheme and we want to give
regular Behavior right we don't want
these like one special case that we have
to handle separately we want everything
to be regular so stay it's not generic
and avoid this list of of the
possibilities well if you stay so
generic there's that you only have to
avoid keeping this too
so
very few cases you have to avoid so
let's start talking about some very old
mathematics investors algorithm
so there are a couple of ways to
decompose a tensor and apart from the
um sort of Brute Force polynomial
solving all I know is that they're all
based on this algorithm so it's very
important to understand Sylvester's
algorithm from around the 1850s
in this range so the first thing let me
give you a little bit of tools that
we're going to need so we're going to
work for binary forms
okay
so if we're given
say l is equal to Alpha X Plus Theta y
then we're going to Define
the polar
is
partial X Plus Alpha of the partial y so
my partials and my alphas and betas I'm
sorry if they look very similar so just
asking if you can't read something so
this is going to be in C2 so this is
going to be n ob2 star the Dual Vector
space so I'm explicitly naming a basis
of each one of the inspector spaces
and there are dual bases because partial
with respect to X and Y are dual to X
and Y
okay and then for
some polynomial F of degree two we have
the fundamental theorem of algebra right
and then two variables
so if we have a function
in some D of C2
well there's two things that we can do
is one
we know it completely factors
so I want to do this
inside of the Dual space for now so this
is always back here so it's always of
the form L1 per L2 per
l
right this is a fundamental theorem of
algebra
so now I'm going to do
I'm going to do what we did with
regulated sensors that have no symmetry
I'm going to perform a flattening
so I have a symmetric flattening these
are also well I'll name the other names
in a second so
foreign
okay so if I have f is a degree D
polynomial I can write down the
following Matrix Associated to the
polynomial which should remind you of
flattening so I'm going to label the
rows and columns by I and J
multi-indices and I'm going to take d by
D
X
I plus J in general but
we only have two variables here so I can
make this even easier in this case right
so
indices
okay let's try this
okay so 5x and Y this is what I'm going
to do
take derivatives with respect to X and Y
of degree D all right and don't worry
I'll give you an example if the notation
is just a little a little difficult but
anyway I'm going to take all possible
with partial derivatives and this Matrix
if you notice it only depends on this is
also a hanko matrix
and then it's also known as a catalactic
and Matrix
so Sylvester was quite the poet I guess
and he used poetry terms to describe
some of his mathematics uh it was
actually
um
either D minus D or e o or for the Y not
b
okay let's let's see this in an example
in a second sorry I don't want to say
the theory first and then for the
example
so what can I do with this
okay so here's the main proposition
that's going to make all of this work
okay so let's suppose L1 to l e are
distinct
and then
there exists some constants
say Lambda I and C such that
this has a solution
so this happens if an ldf
to statement
happens if normally if F factors
sorry f is annihilated by these factors
perfect so this this proposition if you
haven't seen it before well it ends up
being essentially just a dimension count
plus the statement that we wrote right
here
so this this is not a difficult
proposition but it is what what makes
everything work so what's the point
so the point is if
if some polynomial p is in the kernel
of this this map that we just wrote down
is General
well first of all it's it's a polynomial
in two variables homogeneous
so it factors and it has this property
that it annihilates f so it factors p is
L1 for
up to l
curve and
p f equals zero so we can use the kernel
of the catalyptic map or the symmetric
flattening map to tell us the linear
forms in the decomposition of our given
polynomial
so
in the previous lecture and the very
beginning of this lecture I mentioned
that flattenings tell you the Border
rank
or the expected rank for a given format
of tensor well flattenings also tell you
how to decompose the tensor as long as
the rank is really small
so let's do this in an example now that
we have all the theorem report
okay so here we're going to do a binary
keeping
and I picked one ahead of time with a
good coefficients so hopefully
everything will be
clear and not too too messy on the board
Okay so
this polynomial is the sum of two cubes
and we're going to find those two cubes
maybe you can guess them because I mean
the numbers are really nice a big
integer integers ahead of time but let's
just walk through the algorithm okay so
compute
the Cadillac you get now
so this catalactic can goes from soon to
C2 star
just C2
and let's write down the flattening with
labels so d by DX d by d y d x squared
DX
equals square B
those are the labels from the matrices
and let's just fill in
all of the entries
maybe you notice the ankle structure
okay so if I computed all my derivatives
correctly this is um
no you don't like really big matrices so
this is six times nine minus one minus 1
27 27.
okay
you good with this so I made a couple of
choices sort of implicitly in the way
that I'm doing this but they're all
consistent so
um
okay so the next step is to compute the
kernel of this map
it's gonna do really good with learning
Algebra I already know what the kernel
of this two by three Matrix is well if
you've been tired of computed it so
the kernel of CF is the span of minus
five nine
nine two but this is inside of Sim 2 C2
star so it's actually equal to this
polynomial
foreign
my integer Vector as the integer
coefficient so I have a polynomial
degree two and two variables and then I
factor it
and you should not expect this to factor
over the integers but I chose again I
chose this as a nice example so it would
so
okay so this polynomial in factors
and then
these are the polars the linear forms
that I was looking for so I need to swap
them this means that F my polynomial is
equal to some constant I guess it was
calling it Lambda
Lambda 1 times the polar of the first
form is swap the coordinates two x the
plus y
Q Plus on the two
x minus 5y
Cube and then
set coefficients equal
and solve
a linear system
for the lambdas
so I don't know what the lambdas are but
I just solve an easier linear system and
I get Lambda 1 equals Lambda 2 equals
one in this case Okay so it doesn't have
to be 1 1 again it's just for the uh
exposition
okay so I found the decomposition let's
walk through it one more time so I start
with my polynomial I compute the
symmetric flattening of the polynomial
as a matrix that Matrix has a kernel
most of the time as long as the rank is
not too large
so I reinterpret the kernels and again a
polynomial and I factor that polynomial
and then I use the factors I polarize
them and I get linear forms in
decomposition so there's an X bonus so
John asked if anybody remembered the
cubic
the formula for the roots of a cubic so
I've actually just given it to you so
let's solve this cubic equation
solve this cubic equation f equals zero
so we just wrote it f is equal to two X
plus one cubed so I'm going to
dehomogenize just for the sake of what
we're using
just set y equals one okay so if I have
this to sum of two cubes then this means
that uh 2x plus 1 cubed if this equal to
minus
five cubed but then
this thing is that one is equal to 2X
plus 1 over
minus X plus five
cubed okay so Omega cubed equals one
then we have uh x equals five Omega the
J
plus two
okay
so now you know how to solve a cubic
equation there's no formulas to memorize
there's just the Sylvester algorithm to
solve the cubic equation in one variable
okay so any questions about semester's
algorithm because we're going to jump
into eigenvectors and tensors and more
sophisticated algorithms in a second
so can you just like uh just run through
the statements again just quickly to say
so so you have some binary form
you just run through like maybe the
slide with the red oh okay so so I start
with my binary form and I and I'm this
proposition is telling you why the
kernel
fact the factors of the kernel actually
give you linear forms okay so it says
that if I compute this Matrix right
the kernel is a subset of polynomials
over here but these guys all Factor
because the fundamental theorem of
algebra and moreover they Factor as the
product of polars of linear forms just
by working the Dual basis
so the proposition says that uh
this product here annihilates my form so
I'm looking at this is in the kernel of
the catalyptica map
if and only if this is satisfied so the
proof of proposition is just compute the
dimensions of the of the two Vector
spaces involved
so you choose
the rank
no no the Matrix determines the rank for
me so it could be that the kernel is
empty then I just stopped the algorithm
I can't say anything else in fact if you
pick a generic rank form this is
probably going to happen to you
I I would think of it as you start say
you want to start cheap and write it as
eight well that
so let's go to sum of two cubes then you
do this Sim 2 The Sim D minus two that
is a kernel you
use the algorithm that fails you go to
Sim 3 to D minus three
and you keep on going until you get a
kernel so if I I hope that I will have
time at the end to state ethereum which
tells you precisely when this algorithm
works and precisely than an X algorithm
works but but I just want to like make
sure the algorithms are clear and then
we'll say the balance what does failure
mean failure means like this form well
in this case uh
you know the way I set it up this map
always has a kernel right so and I can
always work through this but maybe you
know for you can imagine if there are
more than two variables then the
polynomial won't Factor they won't have
any solutions over over the rational
numbers for instance or even in the
complex
um you can also Imagine when the degree
is higher we get a square catalytic
Matrix and it still has no and then it
has no kernel
I'll just maybe let me just skip ahead
and I'll tell you just do it so
I'll just tell you when was when this
algorithm actually succeeds
I wanted to make a comment if you think
of this in terms of the calories inverse
system do you know what it is and to
associate it to the cubic we have the
groin skin ring the two variables a Zero
Dimensional guarantee in two variables
which is a complete intersection so
there's two generators look at the
smaller degree generate a computer if
this generate a factor is
you can do it if not you have to go to
the higher degree generators and
a general linear combinations of the one
the higher will give you
the presentation
so there's a huge community of algebra
interpretation of these things which is
super interesting I'm trying to stick
just to the most basic nature season so
on but this is exactly the true like you
said good point so here's the theorem
and I should attribute mostly to um
arabino and Canada but they made a small
a small Improvement
foreign
so they have a nice book on this type of
these type of methods
so um the catalyptic and algorithm and
Sebastian's algorithm
succeeds
well when the following cases one if D
is even
um
an R is less than or equal to M plus
okay so m is
n minus one
which is 10.
and plus one equals the number of error
steps
what is coefficiency
so this is what is succeeding does that
mean assuming you can factor the
polynomial or okay so I'll give you the
result statement okay so let's let
um the I equals 1 to R
l i the D equals F in general
among of rank r
and then set you z i is the line Through
The Eyes the capital Z is the collection
C1 to the CR
depending on Heaven I guess I want to
round this
okay
so
so this is this should have been ahead
of time and I'm about to finish the
statement but
um
I haven't completed this sentence yet
okay so if
if D is even or D is odd
and R is less than or equal to n plus M
minus one which is n with no extra
subtraction then
the kernel
c f the most square
catalactic is equal to the ideal of
degree M Vanishing the ideal of
polynomials of degree m
anishing on Z
the Subspace
of degree m
polynomials
Vanishing
on on the set Z
so the kernel is actually equal to
the polynomials which vanish on on the
forms we're looking for and the
algorithm succeeds
foreign
for the kernel
of Cl so sorry the statement is really
long because it's really technical but
the point is supposed to be that as long
as the Border rank or the ranked R is
less than this this number in the even
case or less than this number in the odd
case then the algorithm will finish
there's
but this assumes you know how to find
the zero cellular collection well we
translated a hard problem to not quite
as hard problem but still a hard problem
all right I mean you still have to solve
so have to solve this system upon
operations because it's a smaller system
than what we started with
so there's one other there's one other
case what could happen that you may have
more points
than than the number of forms in the
decomposition so another thing that
could happen is if D is even
and plus um choose minus n in this case
with this then the algorithm
this the algorithm succeeds but
you know
so Z Prime is going to be the zero set
it's right over there but it's small
okay so the zero set of the kernel of
the catalyptic map could be larger than
the number of points that you want but
it's still finite and uh
okay
forgot the word kernel
okay so I I go through my algorithm I
compute this kernel I compute the zeros
it could be that I have more zeros than
the number of forms in my decomposition
I'm sub-generic ranks so I know that I
should expect a unique decomposition and
after finite limiting checks of subsets
of these uh these points I could find
the decomposition
so I'm taking away the one right but in
this case in this case you exactly get
the the same number of points in the
zero set as the number of forms as R
yeah
so I guess the point is this cuts the
degrees of the equations you need to
solve a payoff
and how it it reduces it depending on
what R is I guess so I don't know yeah
algorithm
I could see the degrees are double but I
don't see how many equations here we
have equations depends on the size of
the kernel yeah right so you should
expect the currently in fact
in this case you just pick a generic
element to the kernel and it factors and
in the other case you actually have to
solve an existing of linear equations so
it's best to just check these things in
practice I think like just implement it
into your computer and see what happens
okay so we did this you can download our
Macaulay 2 code off of the ancillary
files and archive attached to our paper
so if you're interested with Giorgio
wrote I'll do things in the Colley too
just to see what's really happening okay
so now I want to sort of switch gears a
little bit so that I can describe the
the best algorithm that I know uh their
questions
here we are taking the headlight when
you say General of branches at least
generic independent yeah we're trying to
avoid some interesting or pathological
cases where
um you know there are a couple of cases
here maybe that this could fail but as
long as I avoid a close set then it's
going to be true and
very very
is it efficient
so I can't tell you the efficiency of
this algorithm you just have to check it
on the computer okay like I didn't do a
complexity analysis for the algorithm
you have to you have to do some work
sometimes but as long as the rank is
small you hope that you can actually
yeah
yeah but it depends how many there are I
mean in two variables you just have to
factor a low degree polynomial so that's
fairly easier than the naive and more
you have this you have to find the zero
set of reflection of
polynomials so it's like your original
question but they're lower degree and I
think the fewer equations as well
so your life is slightly less visible
okay so let's let's hold the rest of the
discussions till after if that's okay
next topic I want to talk about is
eigenvectors and tensors
these were invented in around 2005.
by lamb and independently by the key
and there's been since a lot of work on
spectral theory of tensors and I just
want to introduce this because it's a
key to the next algorithm for
decomposing symmetric tensors so so
let's just recall matrices
just so we know
it's supposed to have a matrix that goes
from a vector space to B and linear map
and I have the instead of v and I have
Lambda and satellite field then
eigenvalue equation is MB the slider V
we all know this
I could also
eliminate the
need for the eigenvalue which my
colleague in linear algebra don't
necessarily like this but
this is the same thing as saying that MV
and V point in the same direction
so
this is the same
way of thinking of an eigenvector but
you eliminate the eigenvalue which may
or may not be a good choice Okay so
with polynomials
then
let's take some polynomial and some D of
V
so how do I Define an eigenvector of a
polynomial well here's the most
straightforward way I know how to think
about this so I'm going to do the first
flattening
and
maybe Jam doesn't like this but I'm
gonna
save dsv star so just ignore all the
stars in the picture so this will be a
way I can define an eigenvector so C1 P
of D now I can
it's something of degree D minus one and
spit out a vector in V again
is some Lambda V
if this happens
we say
V is an eigenvector
of P
with uh eigenvalue
but I can also ignore the eigenvalue
and just write C of eating B B minus 1
times wedging b equals zero
right
okay let's compute an eigenvector as a
polynomial
let's suppose I take the product of
three variables and just try this one so
here's C1 and P
okay so I'm going to label x y z and
then I'm going to label these guys x
squared x y
XZ
y squared Y and Z and Z squared so those
are my labels and my Matrix and then the
only places I get a one and the Matrix
are when x y z occurs
okay so that's my my flattening Matrix
and now I'm going to eat
B1 X Plus V2 y plus V3 to Z squared
and I get a system of equations
so this is C1 P eating this guy right so
this is also equal to D1 squared V1 V2
with the two
B one two three the two a two squared V2
B3 with the two in front and then B3
squared this Vector kind of
okay
this is it clear I I just used the
variables X Y and Z to hold places but
then I Square this out and this is the
vector I'm actually feeding my Matrix
so I get a system of equations
now that I have to solve so
if I'm going to have C1 p b squared
equals V times the Lambda then this
means that I have to have
two V two B three
two three one
two municiple
because I saw that three
um I'm just going to set Lambda equal to
one for this for this problem
okay so the solutions
well maybe you can see right away that I
need bi to be equal to plus or minus a
half
and then some of the signs are going to
work and some of the signs are not going
to work so there's
check the check the signs
okay
so I can either have the
v i v j and V K be all plus I could have
a minus plus plus minus plus and I get a
minus minus minus so the system is
completely symmetric
this collection of science can work in
this collection of science can work
these two collections of science cannot
work so this is uh four Solutions
so one two three four
so this is for eigenvalue one eigenvalue
one also three solutions
good
I picked one for fitness
okay so um now you might want to know
how many eigenvectors are there for a
given tensor so Tammy called to ask this
question to uh Baron and his student at
the time Dustin Cartwright and they were
able to answer this question
using torque geometry and here's the
answer so theorem
Cartwright
the number
of
independent
eigenvectors
a of a general
laughs
Maybe
so this is cm
because this beautiful formula
and then when D equals two just take the
limit you just love the top scroll
forget the formula okay so we know how
many eigenvectors of the tensor we
should expect by this theorem there's
also a way to count this by using churn
Clauses and Vector bundles which uh
Jojo and I explained in our paper
okay so now let me connect in the
three plus whatever discussion time we
need connect this to tensor
decomposition okay so what what do you
Salvage if you what okay that number
doesn't change but if you make a change
or coordinate so the identification of V
with three dual changes I just did that
example you don't need that
identification okay so this is this is a
well-defined it's a well-defined thing
without I just wanted to write a clean
example of the lower biologic discussion
about duals and optimals okay okay so
here's an example
Hilbert
quintix
okay covered context so Howard
um Valentini and Rosen said the
following
you know
they're old enough that we don't have to
write them in so a general
F inside of sim 5 C3
has a unique decomposition
so this example
we didn't have the genital key so I
don't get four or three
seven so that's why I do value one and
three
okay okay next
in the next example we will get the full
Summit okay thank you
um
a general
playing quintic has unique decomposition
as the sum
of seven
fifth powers
and unique means up to the obvious
rescaling and reordering
okay so I want to give you an
algorithmic proof of this statement but
also like how to decompose a plain
quintic and if you if you think the
algorithm is just limited into this one
case node it I won't have time to
discuss all of the cases for which this
algorithm works but let's just follow
the what we should do so step one is
just check
the Cadillac tickets
so what are the sizes of the possible
Cat Electric and so they can have here
well they're going to be sent three of c
3 star to Sim 2 c 3 this is a six by ten
this cannot attack rank 7.
so the the celestial algorithm will fail
guaranteed for this general form
okay so step two
so matanyani generalized strassan's
equations to a larger class of equations
called exterior flattenings also called
young flattenings and Landsberg and it's
aviana's paper
so these are new equations
and they're going to also provide the
key to finding composition so what we're
going to do first is we're going to
twist
twist the catalactic and by the causal
Matrix
so let me remind you of the possible
Matrix I care about K is going to go
from C3 to C3
and the first causal Matrix you may have
learned is this one zero x y z
minus sign here zero zero minus X Y
let's see okay this beautiful three by
three skew symmetric Matrix depending on
three variables X Y and Z so what's the
twist The Twist is I'm going to take k
twisted
so now
this is going to be cp2
oh the two is five cylinders
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take the derivative with respect to
whichever variable here of the form p
and I'm going to write the block Matrix
CPU so let me write the Matrix and then
I'll say the dimension to the song
There's A C partial x p
negative C partial y
Z partial C
partial X2
C partial y minus
0.
where C partial x p for instance is from
the center of c 3 to start to say two of
C3
so this is a
six by six Matrix and then I have a six
by six a three by three Matrix with six
by six blocks so this is 18 by 18.
foreign
so the twist is sort of really twisted
right so I'm taking the X here
and I'm taking the derivative with
respect to X onto the P the polynomial
I'm starting with so I'm twisting the
cut the catalytic matrix by taking a
derivative of the form before I form the
catalyptic Matrix then I'm collecting
all the possible ways of doing that into
this blocked Matrix which is looks Q
symmetric and since the blocks are
symmetric it is Q symmetric so we know
that it even size
excuse symmetric Matrix
has determination this is a square it's
just the fafian right
so here's the facts so one
um K Circle B is linear
and P
so this implies that if P has ranked
so I need one more thing
and two if P has ranked
one then
okay
a two
so these two facts imply with the sub
additivity of Matrix rank that if
rank
of P equals R then rank
2R
okay so I made this bigger Matrix and it
may not have helped me any but what I've
done is I've I've tripled the size of
the Matrix but the rank of the Matrix
only goes up by double from what the
catalytic case does so I get a little
bit bigger range for which I can detect
the uh the rank of the tensor and it
turns out that so in this case if uh P
has rank is
seven then
okay Twisted CP as rank
less than or equal to 14. so this means
the 16 by 16 puffins
vanish
and also I have a four-dimensional
kernel
probably what the PS4 to write
so uh all I mean I can work past to the
closure so if it has rank seven it's
true if it has border rank seven still
two okay so I have a four-dimensional
kernel but now let's look at what this
kernel is so what is my what are the the
spaces in which I map from uh where is
this
not going
well I did a Twist so K Circle C P is a
map from Sim 2 C3 so our tensor C3 now
to sim two c three eight sensor C3 with
the star I lift the star out over here
okay so I just told you I have a four
dimensional kernel in this map
and the kernel is in this space here
foreign
polynomials for which I know how to
compute the number of eigenvectors right
here
so a general element
in this kernel
has seven eigenvectors
and and then
the key observation is that these
eigenvectors
are the linear forms
or the Li
in the decomposition
so this is the the thing that we proved
in our paper is that in general if you
start with again a low rank polynomial
first try the catalytic and algorithm if
that doesn't find the rank for you and
if the if it fails then try the cozul
algorithm the the exterior flattens
algorithm which is take a possible
Matrix
use it to twist the catalyticate matrix
by taking partial derivatives and
blocking the Matrix compute the kernel
of that Matrix
then compute eigenvectors of the general
element in the kernel and as long as you
find a finite number of eigenvectors
generally will from this formula then
you can
find the linear forms and decomposition
again Computing these eigenvectors is a
hard polynomial problem but it's not as
hard as the original problem that we
started it's a particular the item
vectors don't depend on what element you
take
that's right
General element
and the reason why it was taking this
wedge product is we also form something
slightly more General when we have
exterior Powers instead of just copies
of C3 so we can define a slightly more
General type of eigenvector and we also
count the number of those eigenvectors
which we needed for for this alcohol
okay so I've overused my time but I I
hope that uh clearly explains thank you
very much
so we still have a couple of minutes for
some more questions for Luke
yeah so you've taken sort of these
original large system of equations which
have very high symmetry structure to
them and reduced it down to a smaller
set of equations do you know of other
applications where you can use this does
it work for General tensors instead of
symmetry tensors so
um that's also the topic of current
research can you do exactly the same
algorithm but what does it mean to do
that for symmetric tensor so John said
you know you have the system of equip
polynomial equations that have a lot of
structure and can you solve other
problems with this kind of idea so um
yes I think we can but we need to try it
by the way this algorithm is also
implemented in my quality two and takes
a half a second to solve this problem if
we start with rational numbers odd one
one computer not with 50 passengers so
um and we if I had time to ride on the
board you know I could ride an 18 by 18
Matrix we could have done it by hand
actually if we started with professional
solution so
for certain ending you got you use this
to show that there was
seven you can get the seven some of the
fifth powers for more General energy
yeah so the the other case that we can
solve that sort of demonstrates where
this is working the Sylvester's
pentahedral theorem
so um
sorry I didn't have time to explain all
of it but if you have taraner and cortex
we can also solve ternary cortex
so the seven three
sorry
quit Turner in cubics of C4
in this case the general form has is the
sum of
five cubics and Sylvester had a
pentahedral method for solving it a long
time ago but now this algorithm works
but we actually need to consider
um you know super Sim 3
uh V we first lift this to view tensor V
tensor V and then we lift again to B
sensor wedge to the tensor it's
complicated he starts into B and then
our casual map ends up being a map
uh this K circle of C is ends up being a
map like this B Star tensor wedge to the
to V Star sensor V and when we construct
this map we now need eigenvectors of
tensors that are of the following form
they're the form so d v tensored wedge a
V
of this type and we can also compute the
number of eigenvectors of this type as
well by a similar churn class formula
so we actually needed it for the
Sylvester pentahedral equation or
theorem
to do the decomposition so
slightly more General than what lemon
keep and Chi defined that very analogous
so people actually do this in practice
in numerical practice they use iterative
methods for finding
eigenvectors
decompositions do you see a connection
has this been explored how this I might
tie in with the iterative methods
so I think the place for iterative
methods so first
so I actually did this in in Matlab for
the the Hilbert quintix is that write
down all of these matrices now in Matlab
so that you can compute the kernel
numerically now I have a general
polynomial here but it won't have all of
the nice rational properties that I had
before but I can still try to use a
power method to find the eigenvectors
here so I would like to try to do
something like I iterate just you know M
times V compute the norm divide by
renormalize and keep going keep
iterating and I think that's the place
to do it is when you're trying to find
the eigenvectors in this kernel a
general element in the kernel you should
then apply numerical methods to find it
because
we don't expect to have a rational
solution to that the eigenvector problem
so I think exactly at that place is
where we should use the iterative
methods
all right let's thank Luke again
foreign